tracy's in lexington kentucky hi tracy
welcome
to the ramsay show how can we help hi
dave i have a quick question i think
it's pretty cut and garage
to whether or not to hit i'm 53 years
old my husband's a retired school
teacher i still i started late i stayed
home with the kids so i'm
seven to nine years before i can get
before multiple
full teacher pensions my question is
we have 14 years left on our home
mortgage at
a rate of two points our interest rate
is 2.75
do we continue to hit outside of our
pension now we'll both have a pension we
have 401k
and raw what should i be hitting the
hardest with the market returns it looks
like the 401k
returns much better than 2.75 which is
on our
home mortgage are you definitely free
except your home
um no we have 17 000 on
one vehicle before before we even have
this discussion that has to go
okay so your number one thing is
clearing that up
do you have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses
yes how much uh
right at 20 000. oh good pay your car
off today yeah
okay yeah that's all yeah then
then your next number one you're then
your number one goal
and i want you to do a written detailed
budget
with your husband your number one goal
is to build your emergency fund back up
yeah what's y'all's annual income
um right out right at 100. good so this
is going to you're going to do this very
quickly very quickly
very quickly if you're not willing to
pay the car off today you should sell it
yeah okay okay because you've already
you're already owned the car the only
question is are you going to own the
debt so we're going to clear the debt
now you don't have a car payment anymore
i'm going to build your emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
that's going to take you about four
months is all
and then we're going to start baby step
four
which is 15 of your income going into
retirement
and everything else we can find we're
going to throw at that house yeah
okay okay and i i think i'm at
9 8 into my retirement already i forgot
to mention that that's already
you need to you may want to stop that
temporarily till you get that emergency
fund rebuilt
and then start it again at 15 and that's
household incomes your husband work
um he is currently starting a second of
business he's a
with a retired teacher and he's
currently starting but that's
not income anything expense nor income
at the moment
okay if it starts creating an income 15
of your household income
goes into retirement that's what we call
baby step four that's when you're
debt-free with an emergency fund
that's the first three steps then four
is 15
of your income going into retirement
everything above 15 and by the way
without this big stinking car payment
and by living on a budget you're to have
money above the 15 percent
to go ahead and clear that mortgage off
because in seven years i want this house
gone
house debt gone and when you move into
retirement you're gonna have a healthy
401k a healthy pension
he's gonna have a business going and
you're gonna have a paid for house
that's where you want to be at
retirement yep
right yeah that's my goal i i come i
have a money
fear i'm one of those people whose
parents didn't do they did everything i
shouldn't do so i have
almost an irrational fear of not having
money when i'm
older um well the step that we gave you
gives you both wealth and stability yes
wealth is in the 401k stabilities in the
paid for house
right and the the process i just gave
you is the shortest distance
between where you are and there okay
fifteen percent into retirement after
the trucks pay off the truck for sale
after the emergency fund's in place
after emergency fund's back in place
okay then 15
into retirement and everything else we
can squeeze out of the budget we chunk
on the house
how much do you owe on your home uh
184
yeah it's going to be it's probably
going to be seven to nine years before
you're done
yeah you may not have it done in seven
years but you're going to be close
depending on if your husband starts
adding some income to the equation or
not
yeah and he starts adding income to the
equation you start throwing it at that
and don't allow your fear
tracy to prevent you from getting to
your your purpose as far as not your
purpose but your future
pay off the car today all right pay it
off today
and you'll get closer and closer and
closer to your dream i think you can do
it within seven to eight years
um but the numbers do show seven and
nine but i think if you and your husband
really sit down get on a clear budget
i think you can be there within seven
years twenty five thousand dollars
is eight years out of a hundred
sure you can do it faster than that
probably you probably can do it in
because the income should go up with the
business yeah yeah i i do i think you're
gonna be done in seven years
if you stay concentrating on it right i
mean you don't have to live on beans and
rice to do it but i think you're just
going to pay attention
be very intentional with your money hang
on i'm going to send you a copy of the
book the total money makeover which
outlines those baby steps that we were
using in detail
it's like the baby steps on steroids
that's what the book is and it's the
best-selling book we've ever done
because of that because it gives
everybody a clear path of exactly what
to do here
what to do there what to do there and
what to do there that's simple